les chéris des gens va démarrer par la
une de public qu'on en exclusivité alors
là une de public
est ce que vous connaissez michel
polnareff michel polnareff et son sont
juste amis je pense mais il fait la une
de public avec quelqu'un qu'on a reçu
ici regarde avec afida turner
alors y mettent ils sont ensemble ils
vont chez quoi faire ensemble c'est
surtout ils vont chez le copain ensemble
incroyable mais vrai alors moi je
connais les deux a priori ils sont très
amis mais on s'est amusé à savoir à quoi
allait ressembler leur fils au cas où
regardez ça donnerait sa il est il est
hyper mignon est énorme alors voilà non
mais c'est fou ce type mais c'est pas
possible ce que vous avez des infos qui
a déjà tout ce que je peux vous dire
ouais alors allez-y
j'ai réussi à filer teneur de mon bureau
une quinzaine de jours pour une mission
sur des gens de télé réalité tout ça et
j'avais très sympa les sympathiques on a
fait étape en a rigolé on n'était que
trois ans bureau mois on associer les
game frisquet elle et moi d'accord et
pendant qu'on parle à monet le téléphone
sonne sa fiche
michel polnareff mais elle répond très
sale ubb mach attraits comme ça et
guillaume qui ont à ce qu'il ait mis si
vraiment polnareff suis fan a pris le
téléphone et mr par là lui a parlé donc
c'était vraiment michel pena a une
mission très amis
c'est lui qui téléphonaient ont été je
rentre à los angeles bientôt on verra
il n'y a pas eu de temps la norme ça
mais ce qui est vrai en tout cas c'est
que c'est lui qui a téléphoné sur son
téléphone elle a répondu c'est et bbc
très proche passé essayant voilà qu'il
disait et astrid on ne sait pas voilà
maintenant s'ils veulent mais si j sont
heureux j'adore mon chef enfin voila
c'est peut-être le moment de mettre des
lunettes un peu moins teinté par contre
vous c'est peut-être le moment de faire
des bonnes vannes